finalement j'ai pas combien de tmx est
perdue en fait honnêtement pour pas pour
te dire la vérité sur le nombre de jours
en fait j'en sais plus rien mais je
crois bien que ça va être le 17 ou 18
ans aujourd'hui
ouais en date dans ces eaux là mais je
pourrai compter en arène du coup me et
c'est pas près de s'arrêter
ouais c'est pas près de s'arrêter et a
passé la mauvaise nouvelle ou pas mais
il ya un truc qui nous tilt en fête avec
ses amis j'en parle directement je crève
la le sait c'est qu'il ya un bug et on
sait pas comment créer un problème pour
créer des arènes mais le truc c'est que
deux bases je pensais que c'était un
problème qui était lié car mon compte en
fait georges avait un bug mais sami a le
même pack ouais c'est pareil pour moi en
fait on a un petit plus sûr pour créer
le tournoi et la justice par une
interface donc où un stand de rien faire
alors je pense que ça va être réglé
assez rapidement ouais écrit moi sur sur
le truc du staff j'ai écrit dans le
général hors jeu baptisé le doigt un
endroit pour écrire ça tape plus de
chanter dans une réponse au mans ouais
rapide
ouais je me dis que c'est celui qui
était le plus qui souffre d'un syndrome
qui touche le plus de personnes pas tout
le monde qui est dedans normalement et
en plus je crois que ouais ça mais mais
du coup je sais pas quoi faire
pas de direct par le club est ce que ça
changera quelque chose
goguenard qui est déjà là non pour créer
trois mois je passe toujours aussi par
la même interface en tout quatre
candidats oui en fait matin les
résultats
oui là c'est juste le résultat
historique c'est ça
nouveau tournant direct voulais vraiment
cette attente est on peut ah ouais ok en
cliquant par là bien joué du coup j'ai
un groupe non importe quoi très bien je
les connais j'ai bien ri connard en fait
tu peux passer comme ça et le et le crès
quoi par contre non parce qu'il ya un
bug ici parce que là tu es dans le top
30 yens ouais ouais avec le club france
eut admis donc non je suis censé pouvoir
le crès oui berges les faits hier mais
en fait débloquez ici donc il ya bien
buggé endroit quoi ouais c'est le
système ouais alors attends je vais
essayer si jamais avec le club dit
stream tu vois on sait jamais que j'ai
un bug de ce qui est bizarre c'est
quelqu'un plein de tournois au cours ou
déjà créé ouais alors attends c'est être
des gars qui les ont créés ya longtemps
louis est peut-être le coup s'est pas
fait tout seul truc mais attends attends
attends on va pas paniquer façon pire
n'y a pas de tournoi que j'ai envie de
te dire c'est pas non plus la fin du
monde mais à
mais déjà on va pas quelle on va pas
capituler alors j'en suis à nouveau
tourné en direct
oui il ya des partis majoritaires aussi
par un vote a déjà eu ce test avec le
don c'est pareil bug contre le chat la
notation est il ya un bug avec les clubs
oui c'est ça ni un bug avec les clubs et
donc toi t'as faim tu as pas le plus bas
c'est exactement match pour essayer non
pas son temps par le club lui qui attend
après on peut se faire un délire c'est
qu'on se met tout sur une arena qui est
jouable alors retrouvé il y en a une
dans 21 ème essai du 10 +0 il y en a une
dans 5 + 0 qui commence dans 25 minutes
à 13 heures
ce qu'il obtient tu peux fille laisse
lire moi je te dis au pire on se fait ça
n'ont à tanger bonne solution
c'est une solution alternative mais qui
peut nous sauver quoi tout à fait
toujours des solutions
j'ai bien sûr le dock hautement donc on
va juste regarder quelle est la reina
qui est la plus intéressante pour nous
et on va aller et on va les détruire en
fait c'est ça le truc
ouais les mecs mois tant sur les ailes
que j'ai trouvé en 5 + 0 venant 25
minutes allait pas mal j'ai envoyé le
lien dans le tchat
je pense qu'on peut leur faire très très
mal à la tête dans cet aréna à bas on va
les détruire enfin ils vont être heureux
de se faire détruire en fait
mais oui mais ça les changera c'est à
dire que là en fait voilà c'était déjà
route ou baguette qui est dedans il ya
maugrée faut la fête ils vont qui
traversent au pas il ya 152 ans et 10
ans crise
ouais c'est ça on va faire en fait on le
plomber devient un plan à moi je propose
qu'on détruit cet aréna en fait ça on
l'a on trustent tous cavier le droit abu
jarad prêtre camaro spark en fait qu'on
soit tout cela devant et avec les mecs
ne puisse plus exister quoi on la
remarque jour dessus en fait savoir que
des drapeaux français dans les premières
places comme ouais c'est ça le monde en
sueur face à la france soit exactement
mais là c'est beaucoup quoi les mecs ne
font vraiment pas comprendre ce qui leur
arrive en fait on préfère faire tous les
jours d'ailleurs à sedan on va
entreprendre une arena ont détruit tout
le monde quoi dégager
on ne veut plus voir en fait vous ne
vous intéressez pas mal mais c'est cool
gaza
de carbon il ya toujours façon des
moyens de de trouver du positif dans le
négatif
et c'est quoi le petit plus que jacques
était une chaise comme tel c'est juste
pour un sou vingt six élèves sous
participer ce puits cela non c'est pas
ok c'est pas c'est un bon point puisque
j'ai un peu regardé les dépôts je crois
que ça avec eux c'est avec dance crew
qui sont clashés ouais ouais mais j'ai
vu que l'objectif donné pause c'était de
faire re tous trois mille trois cents
mais il va jamais y arriver il n'a pas
le niveau hockey après celle à quel
point il a l'expérience sur internet
donc un petit peu mal progression ce
type n'est pas un athlète tu vas le
comprendre ce type n'est pas un athlète
c'est un avatar d'internet
du coup les jo 3-1 3-0
on n'est pas en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'il est plus l'endroit où il est
souvent mal autant dans les faux j'ai
regardés curieusement way après moi je
pense pas que la souris ou quoi ça
puisse être un désavantage pour lui vu
qu' il est très bon à dota 2 aux jeux
vidéo et et c'est vrai je pense juste
qu'il est moins fort qu'un a qu'un c'est
tout oui oui mais dans ce cas il doit
faire ça justin sur internet 5 heures
par jour depuis dix ans quoi ouais non
ménaka est plus fort en glisse dans tous
les cas ouais mais aucun des poèmes pas
si loin je pense en oublie de ce réel
ouais mais là ils sont rigolos ces deux
fous là où de 3,7 rend super préfet pas
fou de joie pas je vois pas où il est de
quoi table je vois pas la tactique ne
peut qu on est peut-être la dame qui
vient à être ça qui est ça le sou là
mais juste dommage de claquer 50
secondes là-dessus quoi ouais les gars
voulaient plus
kas bourse le sourire car oui cette
année
si c'est le cas van le gallia bertrand
pour l'instant très très moche n'a
aucune case c'est une pièce car dominer
dans le nom mais l'impact d'internet
c'est pas possible
enfin je relaxe c'est ridicule il vient
de claquer une minute 20 c'est bizarre
en fait tu donnes la partie en faisant
ça on en fait ça devrait bouger
impressionnant bah ouais il joue avec un
incrément je pense qu'ils veulent
vraiment que le meilleur sur l'échiquier
ya très peu peut-être sont dues sont
réglées justement parce qu'il se faisait
tomber sans dire ok bah je veux pour de
vrai du coup et pour autrefois du coup
[Musique]
ouais non non rien mais c'est d'abord il
avait poussé 6 des cinq libéreront
laquelle des quatre cavaliers et
commenceront être davantage aux qui on
va dire en pratique 25 x 4 très faible
cherchait il est dans le dur là ouais
bah je souhaitais cisco jeu parce qu'il
fait la fête tout comme toi tu craques
un maître jacques à bâle et même sens
qu'il veut c'est faire de petits réseaux
n'a rien à 4 si vous voulez ok mais là
tu fait qu'elle ait des cats et tu me
l'as des si cela te fait des décisions
déjà comme ça tu as le petit cahier f5
échec non il le fait dans ce sens là ok
un choix qui n'a pas été très propre
dans toutes plus en plus ils sont pas
mal réfléchi pour des cours à ses yeux
son prix doivent calculer des choses
qu'on voit pas certainement d'avoir des
explications
changes détroit bon j'y crois pas trop
a lyon des va être relou mais après
voilà m ux échos pierre on va commencer
à faire sacrifier le fou en fait même la
finale tourne trop les deux piasses elle
m'a gagné avec 1 4 qui tombe au cas où
tu peut sacrifier le ouf
ouais la r31 président
il veut juste rallier assez bien joué
ouais il est en train de sombrer et
ouais mais il va lui prendre le vent
tombe ici c'est lé plus sympa du tout
c'est fort au cavaliere j'ai eu beaucoup
de tours ouais sur concrètement tu
prends un belliciste envoie b après
ouais il craque complètement nouveau
c'est l'épaule il a les blancs il craque
complètement ce sécheresse a regardé va
se prendre le pion bessette est fou b5
et le carré découvre les bagarres qui
avaient prend tout reprend b737
mais c'est ça regarde dans l'es17 ce
fait d'armes nice et j'ai l'impression
qu'il s'est mis la pression tout seul je
joue bach o'conner je vous observe le
premier le lien vers l'aréna et on nous
dit salut je suis débutant aux échecs
qui aurait une sortie à me conseiller
bakou tu peux j'avais fait la vidéo sur
les causses est vrai que je la retrouve
gérard bon début et ce soir sur elle est
partie pédagogique contre les débutants
du coup ça vous rendez vous
auch le diaconat
qu'est ce qu'il y fait j'ai pas entendu
il dit première à gauche pour la sortie
parce que effectivement pas ressortis
assez interne un petit peu inusitée j'ai
raconté chiens dits plutôt ouverture
ouais c'est pas faux et 1,5 hier mon
premier scream sur tweets chez tout le
monde m'a dit que j'utilisais 95% des
expressions bas c'est normal c'est les
meilleures expressions faut le savoir
oui mais possède bien je sais pas trop
comment prononcer ya chez ischios je
sais pas y'a pas une signification ont
réussi une réforme structurelle cacher
je pense qu'il ya une force qui ne rêve
caché mais je n'ai pas ok leçon de samy
est un peu cas vers 1 ne t'es un peu
caverneux mais je ne suis pas tellement
le raconte dans les points clés
caverneuse mais peut-être tu parles pas
ça par contre c'est possible mais on n'a
pas dit que justement le le saut moteur
un petit peu plus forme au sommet après
moi je les mille et justement je vais
régler un fort alors peut-être du coup
ça donne cette impression comme tu
parlais plus bas quoi mais j'ai mis du
un peu de gains ok voyons un peu trop
fort mais alors attendre un peu enlevée
de gains on a un peu rajouté la fête
est ce qu'on a le lien oui alors
attendons jeu ça commence à calar d'une
roue à la demie ça commence à la nuit
c'est qu'il adversaires de négoce et
feydeau cf et de cf qu'un grand maître
russe kia je sais pas combien d'amateurs
27 chose comme ça n'importe tomber
bizarrement l'a peut-être perdue aux as
et 27 mai était très haut et puis à il
est un bon rush il commençait même à m
c'est vrai comme un candidat au mec
puisse en faire un super tournoi depuis
il est retombé dans mon cou être grand
maître à 2400 où il ya alex personnes à
condition d'avoir eu deux mille cinq
cent mille
théoriquement oui d' inception dont bwin
je crois que le but n'est pas que nous
perdons pas tout le monde était fier
d'eux tu perdais trouver nos fils tu
redescends des on vous souhaiter de
mieux
oui mais c'est plus le cas ouais non
c'est plus qu'un pas parce que
maintenant tout le monde défile
heureusement c'est plus le cas il ya
même une époque c'était à 2002 mais ça
on n'a pas connu facile quand on était
vraiment petit ouais fait face à l'ess
2002 pour rentrer field se trouve qui
nous dit qu'on peut perdre le titre de
grand maître
ah oui si on triche si on triche on veut
descendre sous 2011 a manqué un point de
règlement qui dit expressément ce cas de
figure un vélo fichiers doc est ici on
tombe en dessous des 1000
c'est dur mais c'est vrai que si tu
triches tu peut le perdre aussi
ouais mais c'est le seul cas réels en
tout cas précis qu'elle arrivait mais
s'il y aura un autre cas aussi avant lui
puisqu'il avait perdu une petite
deuxième question je sais plus et je
sais plus s'il est perdu ou pas mais par
exemple hao 10 un gars qui a clairement
perdu son titre de grand maître sens
sans tricher sans tricher la région pu
par la suite quoi il avait plusieurs
écoles sur la durée ou la justesse du
coup de
la décision devrait après moi j'étais
performant je suis pas contre une
décision sévère en en choeur ouais faut
toujours prendre l'aspect possiblement
contre mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
faux mais bon est plutôt féliciter nos
ce terme est capable enfin je vous parle
pas assez priori donc en vivant malgré
la perte de son titre de combattre
anglais mec sympa pédagogie de
d'apprendre dans son club aux gens
jeunes et plutôt une bonne image
ouais après mais bon ça n'excuse en rien
de lui même
[Musique]
mcafee qu'une erreur de parcours arrive
pour tout le monde mais non c'est sûr
c'est sûr mais là c'est la grosseur de
parcours des piats les raids étaient
quoi c'est à dire tous les jours et
steve nash de faire une erreur c'est moi
pour moi c'est ça le le souci c'est
surtout le caractère systématique ouais
[Musique]
mais j'ai gardé le titre cramique
cramique topalov le fameux match avec
toilettes gate machin le truc c'était
quand même n'importe quoi ouais
comment détecter la triche sur des gm va
quand même hein ça se voit quand les
mecs commence à trop bien joué mais
avoir des doutes
oui mais bon après c'est un peu le
problème c'est qu'après que le livre
dans le monde de la suspicion constante
et de tank a pas de preuve
problème c'est que justement non non
elle est cachée au fond tout cas moi
évidemment je ne pense pas que cram nick
est riche et qu'outre topalov plateau
qu'elle est traumatisée
je peux te dire que je connais beaucoup
de gens qui le pensent moi j'ai pas
d'avis parce que j étais pas et j'en
sais rien mais je peux te dire que c'est
pas un truc ya pas que topalov qui le
pense et ce que tous peuvent le penser
vraiment déjà mais c'était vraiment son
manager qui tu es
non mais je crois que c'est rendre
romain armand si tu regarde la vidéo qui
nous disaient qu'ils pensent vraiment
quelque chose de louche après ce qu'ils
pensent que non mais cramique il n'a pas
super réputation par rapport à ça oui
mais en fait moi j'ai vraiment du mal à
concevoir ce n était qu avec tellement
fort trichet juste ça me dépasse
tellement que du coup je peux pas je
peux dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
le pense vraiment mais après comme si
moi j'ai pas vraiment d'opinion pour
attendre de façon que c'est pas prouvée
non mais c'est pas à prouver il a pas
triché au moment où le 10 févr
l'instant d'un exemple mais
effectivement c'est une échelle bourde
c'est une triche collective en plus apte
à organiser toit était comment comment
il aurait pu faire pareil c'est un
pratiquement plus difficiles aussi à
mettre au point ses poteaux j'ai moins
de contre x à l'époque et moi
championnat du monde donc à des mesures
de sécurité de vérification quand on
triche pas il utilise des ordinateurs
pour céder ou dans le cas de chroniquer
penser que c'est une histoire de papiers
qu'il allait regarder aux toilettes pour
ces prépas ah ouais mais qu'il a quand
même de voir boost rezé puis c'est pas
la france
quelle ouverture va tomber non plus ou
alors il se souviendra au bout cela
paraît très old school comme moyen de
tricher n'daw j'étais à l'école j ai
fait une bonne entame en hobby formule
c'est ben vrai ça peut aller quand même
aux échecs
ouais j'en vois 17,4 tarrach sais pas je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas j'ai pas
vraiment d'avis dessus d'eux parle du
dopage même si c'est pas un truc qui a
trop traîné les échecs des dragons dont
on contrôle que ça
je veux c'est pas un truc qu'est ce que
tu en penses
ja sa place dans les échecs les
contrôles antidopage et tous ont pas ils
ont voulu faire pour dire que c'est un
sport olympique coi c'était ça l'idée de
fouet c'était de dire ah oui regardez il
ya du dopage on est un sport aussi vers
en soi après peut-être des produits qui
a peut-être déjà je pense juste une
bonne à l'image d'une bonne alimentation
ou quoi ça aide un petit questionnaire
naturel oui naturel tu connais la réf ou
pas non pas du tout un truc à l arrêt
fait durer ya peu de gens qui l'ont dans
le chatt sa trêve tiens la rave du
naturel louis dont le chat
allez on va voir on va voir qui sont qui
sont vraiment les bons raptor donnerai
tous mais ça peut être l raptor mais pas
forcément c'est une réf
c'est pas vraiment à leur app store en
vrai tube ouest vidéo c'est encore un
truc de bodybuilders pas ma spécialité
l'ofce ce qui est peut-être sur la voie
1 34 de mémoire c'est ça avec un petit
robin sent pas naturel oui 600 euros et
plus trop si et quand on wii et quelques
ces experts je t'enverrai le remix il
est exceptionnel ok c'est dur alors
toutes les rêves bah oui on regarde pas
de choses et d'autres choses ah ouais tu
vois la part entre le naturel louis ck
très élitistes comme un bref nintendo
s'est endettée watts position
savoir à quoi tu peux faire référence à
chaque fois ouais ouais non il faut à
faut vraiment avoir avoir du style quoi
y'en a qui font le style ce que j'aurais
pas un petit peu si celle ci avec les
blancs thématique pas très beau a
sûrement pas très bon ce que tu veux
l'accolade à la diagonale pour le four
puis l option même si c'est assez facile
à défendre
voilà il commença menaces mais aussi et
c'est cette réticence des poubelles
quand même cinq et demi à deux ans et
demi elle lui a fait mal la partie avec
la call of après il en a donné une
direct
ouais 3132 il doit être pas mal là à
part à part d'un cas où quelqu'un 3300
ouais ouais mais dans le classement
bliss non mais il est bien mais toute
raison garder quoi yakhi du couquet
juste derrière d'un cas sur votre chat
way doit y avoir du fir où il doit ouais
bon il ya peut être que fier ou quoi
mais à mais encore loin
il ya des gens des fois qu'ils vont tu
sais pas exactement qui m'est à des mecs
qui sont bons angles it's ok c'est pas
avoir la liste du classement à ces mots
les papas que je vais tout je vais tout
faire péter 6 juin au caire en ligne
ok c'est lui c'est un tiens je vais tout
faire péter les arguments et riga ici je
sais même pas qui c'est mon oncle
mais je mène 1 0 contre lui bon allez je
fais tout péter je met les stats
complète du bliss alors beats mondial i
caroubier route jaouen tu voyais pas si
l'on regarde pas raison il prend la
troisième place là et ses kilomètres
ces oeuvres thénia hockey à part à ben
ouais l'art au doux daouda sow feydeau
l'indien way le fameux safar ali qui est
super bon leader
niall sarine grisha sarksian avant
l'arménien donc automatiquement l'attend
à 3 à la c4 la triplette sous toujours
ensemble colchonero je sais pas qui
c'est bon non plus non à rester le
premier ami c'est qui est juste et
autriche à ta teodoro composer leurs
achats bon bah ouais mais je ne voyais
pas aussi aux teodoro joue je sais pas
qui c'est cet argent rouscoff 96 s'est
dit popp aucune qui sait mais bon les
roscoff ça sent toujours des rousses
comme tu connais pas oui
sebastian c'est domingues way après je
sais pas haro gambie manquant de temps
faudra poway placé chinois non titré ça
assez musique ça va être ludique de
lenche il a la même photo de profil eu
en plus
troisième de suite ça peut être que lui
trente scènes il est pas mal mais en
scène il s'est fait un autre content ici
joue sur deux comptes en scène aussi via
le compte chez ce bras et le content de
seine quand même plus facile
jouable avec le wii 24 ans quatre contre
moi mais de l'air pas mal d'être dans le
lot ok pas ridicule j'espère bien il est
pas très bon au final en fait eu
beaucoup de joueurs a pris 3 mais non
ouais troughton casper chauprade il est
bon lui dans les miss c'est dimitri
c'est donc chez n'co je crois 1dans
collard ce pardon raté un arménien serge
une mousse à ces 1990 je pense qu'il a
dû faire 3000 plus la jules
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr il est beau il
est beau largement 3030 tu vois mais
après chose monter plus haut quand même
parce que je joue il a beaucoup joué sur
une chaise comme juge ça fait deux morts
de quoi filer 29,80 laâyoune biz tu as
mvl une veyron ok il a dû monter plus
aussi ouais mais il vous passez super
mutants différence renkin bon après de
façon salata un mélange de tuer igor
nataf km2 1950 rennes je n'ai pas qu'il
n'ya pas jouer ma masse de partie
dommage qu'il estrie pas contre quand
ils jouent en direct qu'on jette avec
moi je dis comme ça peut-être une raison
c'est unique c'est pas mal 29 50 euros
les marckois pas mal placée au dessus de
meilleur groupe admet camille sont super
forts
ouais meilleur meilleur c'est un monstre
depuis les bancs pays chelsea joue et je
voyais tout le temps de jouer sur
internet comscore contre lui 58 à cette
[ __ ] je me fais défoncer à / / 6 /
cette quête et 3050 une défense marc
mais on a des styles
on a des styles qui ne conviennent pas
enfin lui l'a en fait si j'étais plus
fort que lui en fait je le défoncerait
parce qu'avec les styles mais en fait vu
les styles que moi j'attaque est cuit
défend comme il défend beaucoup besoin
de grosses sommes
et tu vois en france et en français je
t'ai pas si mal dans un moment mais mes
gbc voiture et igor il a presque le même
locaux adéquats c'est beau ça j'aurais
pas cru kinoptic il faut beaucoup n'ont
rodrigues est plus que moi j'ai bcge est
arrivé top 4 a abandonné mais gerber
c'est un super coince toujours de
blackmagic heures ouais tu sais qui
c'est ouais il est bon sur le black
power après pour le reste je ne sais pas
le blackberry ne peut des dragons j'ai
terriblement il est pas titre est il de
mettre finances je dis pas de conneries
après il n'a pas beaucoup joué un bon si
c'est bien lui puisque c'est son pseudo
partout j'imagine que c'est nous mêmes
qui a lui aussi l'a pas beaucoup vu ya
des gens qui a pas beaucoup joué et qui
ne sont pas sept ans mais 60 parties de
bridge ce bel s'est par contre je
m'attendais déroula prend la tête en
pensant trucs un peu bizarres et et 2006
a fait une pointe à 20 h 30 après les
retombées
ouais ben on ne sait pas c'est parce
qu'il sait pas c'est lé moment donné du
coup c'est l'heure de la n va commencer
la finale de la dépouille bah ouais bah
il faut que je me remette l'adoption
plus vous fait doux
53e pions ok ça ça doit gagner mais un
cavalier donc en pratique encore se
passer de lui mais des 5 g 24 ans voilée
complètement gagnante mais je pense
qu'elle est pas si simple
enfin moi je pourrais largement de faire
arnaquer par n'est pas là et que le
temps dans l'absolu c'est sûr qu'est-ce
qu'il ya un ou deux vous passez un peu à
jouer et rejouer à brive alors on va
essayer de quitter ces hommes là et voir
nos français à l'oeuvre le reste du
monde mais après j'ai cliqué coupe et en
plus c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
mais mon coeur mon était partie sur
l'autre truc tu vois du coup première
partie c'est déjà les français sont là
font quoi directement à tapis pour mr
lose lose sur souvenir bien sidiki avait
été victime de la plus grosse perf
jusque là dans les arènes il est perdu
contre l'oubli le pseudo 3400 qu'elle
fait une super partie
ouais ouais je me rappelle cette partie
c'est une belle partie ouais qu'avec les
noirs en plus meilleurs voeux du mr nous
donc n'a pas découragé il pourra
vraiment qu'on fasse le taf pour qu'on
gagne le tournoi quoi la c1 pourquoi on
a quand même beaucoup de je pense que
l'on sera on est clairement favori a
beaucoup de représentants je remets
liens dans le tchat
donc du coup on espère presque que les
français se mettent pas trop de sales
coups quoique les parties durent pas
trop bas après ce coup il ya des gros
cubes d'eau par n'a pas regardé
as tu sais jamais le truc c'est qu'avec
les petits lots dans ses arènes
toutes les parutions et azéri à 2000 la
non c'est pas ça se trouve ces rachats
c'est ça mais pas le savoir on attend
qu'il va pas des français devant là je
suis pas rassuré ok ou des suisses ou
des francophones rien tu coupes ou pipe
août l'air de partir forme le roi blanc
un thème très affaibli ici la grande
diagonale blanche a l'air juste
catastrophique avec la menace de la
triple fourchette wave 3 et bien fait
une triplette non ouais triplettes de
belleville
oui mais la dame derrière à il est très
énervé à la ba tour ne m'intéresse pas
je contrôle les casques blancs du
bouffon encore la filière mais ça va
être complètement gagné ici mais après
ils couvrent encore un
il couvre et pour combien de temps by
couvre ses tactiques au delà des
cavaliers f 3 ar c'hoat g3 tu me fous la
f4 et ça va mais on a des fous de
couleurs opposées ça favorise comme
vient la tablette mais call of the plus
t'as pas d'échec on n'en récupère cible
ouais mais ok je prends la calotte je
viens là susu d'accord s'en est bien
sorti ok je lance un petit coup de fouet
f4 comprends tu échanges latu contre
attaque
s'il est en train de se faire tourner
mon petit poupe eh ben j'ai bien
l'impression et mr vous il est choquant
même wii va être un beauf arcade mr nous
donc c'est normal qu'ils trouvent des
ressources
ben may est très fort mais sans loose il
il a très envie de gagner la balle et
très chaud quoi tu connais fraude et
blanche bah ouais je suis promise
[ __ ] la halle et il a regretté le
fait il était tellement mal je vois le
truc se retourne et j'allais mr loudon
nh et la whey toi tu connais bien tous
pipe ou opter pour pop hip hop du coup
on a forcément ça nous va m'en vouloir
du coup certains récents ouais on
regarde regarde les puis on regarde les
pions de mr
jouer ait fait très très mal là mr loose
moi j'ai confiance en poupe mais je sais
qu'il va trouver juste un petit coup
bien caché quelle défense de fer comme
de mr luz assez bien vu leur rêve satie
le tour at 8
ouais as tu avais raison d'avoir
confiance mais à
mais bon il va se prendre un dame de
limonade rentrée et si on échangeait
dame qu'est ce qui se passe c'est pas
terrible mais comment d'un match 5
échecs
t'as plus tard voilà c'est pas grave ça
whoopi poupe
on en a vu d'autres râlent mais il s'est
fait siffler par monsieur loose dont il
devait être complètement gagnant et je
crois qu'à un moment donné il était bien
tu vas voir on sur un peu notre leader
7e best alex and the beast plus il joue
contre caroline afat et donc à 8,1 en
danger comme ça il faut tout de suite le
gall mais déjà mais toujours durant rue
de savoir si l'eau ce livre ou à ses
dépens de l'accent du stress qui
assurent le mot de là il a pas mal du
tout et c'est là on espère bien c'est
une partie importante là c'est notre
leader quoi je pense qu'une partie très
importante pour sa carrière
ah oui là il ya une passe à un tour dont
quand ses responsabilités oui c'est
grand c'est peut-être même plus marrant
de venir se greffer sur une arena des
autres pour un peu les noms ouais c'est
ça change en tout cas du conte se
greffent eon eon les défonce quoi
gagnerait plus une salle arena dégagez
vous nous intéressait plus oui c'est
devant le monde de réussir avant le
monopole des arénas salle
julo tard alors essaie de jouer escale
et java léger 3d fois nova priori un
serveur et non parce que tu contrôles
par la case dire si facile de créer une
attaque du coup y aller il est h3t pas
très bon oui mais n'ajuste anne decis
double attaque ont des deux hématomes à
cheveux ce n'est pas facile à paris où
j'ai la dame et jeunes cavaliers f3
sûreté dans des cases a priori donc
c'est le point pour cette the best way
c'est ça qui s'envole et l'échelon enfin
un petit coup d'oreille riche pour voir
un peu comment ça alors autre joueur
anglais
hocus pocus de voir les autres arènes
elle vient visiter en général 6 quand je
vois c'est pas nous faisons un gros
succès aussi mille deux cent cinquante
ans je m'attendais pas à ça moi non plus
et faire genre de méthode ruiz semi ruiz
quoi un petit côté hippopotames
ouais c'est la bonne nouvelle le fonds
de carte du coup on se retrouve derrière
ses pions donc c'est autres stratégique
c'est juste de faire un peu de sirop f5
on va être plutôt combien avec les noirs
larache catch prouve que c'était bien au
chaud mais ce qu'elle pallie se
recyclera tranquillement les bleus n'ont
pas vraiment d'attac en demande jusqu'à
quel on peut jouer le grand miroir
d'après toi
je prends jusqu'à 27 50 28 ça va après
est-ce qu'en match contre carl scène
pour le titre tu peux utiliser en
ouverture principal je suis pas sûr sur
talent et la grâce d'un demi point en
dessous mais sinon je leur conseille de
vous reparler en miroir ouais ils
vendent choc et n'a qu'à moi comme vous
et quelques uns ont eu des points que au
cap d'agde je prends non ça joue sajou
d'environ sache où il faut vraiment bien
connaître ce passé mais je vais faire
des gandhi muzio quoi je ne connais plus
c'est celui du fils de carayon f3 mais
j'ai 5 pouces et quatre frégates au
maroc je connais je sais pas vous mais
je vois bien ce que c'est mais c'est pas
si mal aux pratiques surtout comblé se
situe prenant même que fondamentalement
c'est pas mauvais ouais
andré qu'il en avait joué quelques uns
aussi ok ça va quand on fait une grande
bagarre c'est nous peut faire un hobby
roi c'est grave ce qui est une ouverture
qui me retient qu'une grave c'est que je
mène en dix ans incarnant vraiment on
avait j'ai regardé j'étais avec l'ordi
et tout c'est le pied c'est vraiment là
que du coup j'ai 4 c'est le seul premier
coup qui donne l'avantagé à l'adversaire
déjà même 3 et wii va ça va ouais ok
avec la peur de moins bien mais tu fais
j'ai trois fous g2 qui a je crois
qu'elle faisait rock ça va coûter 9 3
pour jouer avec eux quatre et je sais
pas oui je suis tombé dans les schémas
classiques avec l 3 en fait j'ai quatre
c'est le seul cookies qui donne
l'avantagé à lundi
c'est bon c'est ça qui donne toute sa
force au cou quoi tu le mets la pression
directe à quatre c'est pas si mauvais la
pièce au premier coup un quart
l'espace le rate
kouakou très sérieuses et l'attaquent
prix je me buzz mais à trois en réalité
je pense tu gardes un microscopique plus
ce qui est sûr est égal si les noirs
jouent correctement et d'ailleurs plein
de manières de jouer correctement
m'étais déjà les moins bien joué à trois
premiers 500 avec les noirs étaient pas
moins bien donc si tu met pas en péril
ta position géré les noirs sont pas
moins bien aux échecs
ok ils donnent davantage loin sur b4 la
fameuse de votants c'est peut-être 0,30
point que la grogne c'est quand même
moins à 50 ou moins 60 déjà prêt pour
une écriture assez basses et celui très
moi j'ai l'habitude avec le black mars
et chamoiseau souvent après après trois
ou quatre couples moisan sa tête on leur
dit quand même
ouais mais - hazard exposition pas
rapidement à un peu sacrifié mois 55
égalité matérielle quand même c'est oui
c'est inquiétant
c'est un peu beaucoup quoi ouais ici les
cavaliers sont pas mal on pense bien la
qualité grand ouais laurent blanc est
très affaibli ducouret il dit il devrait
faire le tas on n'est pas de sitôt
objectivement ce qu'au classement il ya
des philippins qui sont un peu relou la
ba ouai d'un check aussi niveau là c'est
quand même bien partie en cas de
victoires et non strict championnat de
maître fide france et à ses trousses
maintenant ça me rassure quand même mais
bon ils sont ils sont quand même pas mal
aller d'étrangers sur un peu enfin je
n'avais rien aussi à l'arrêt sur google
barbara il faut y mettre les points mais
s'est pas fait c'est pas fait on s'est
pas fait il y à de l'adversité
ouais vous les néerlandais sur une
qualité une pile de plus pour enfermer
une dame mais voilà c'est ça qu'on veut
entendre le torturent les pays-bas en
sueur
face à l'élite ils s'appellent les
pays-bas la r oui c'est pas trop s'il
était si fort et ça paraît les pays au
coiffage simplement soyons sérieux
s'il ya des joueurs que le faire un
point de 8 ce soir pm mois bon ok on pm
qui restent calmes
on va pm je désire pour ton trois par
équipe là ça se passe comment il ya
beaucoup d'équipés qui sont à l écoute
on a appris ce matin et l'équipe de
cannes va être très forte
ouais c'est à dire qu'ils sont très très
énervé a priori zorro benoît c'est le
bel team bmc j'ai toujours eu un bug
avec shell s'est pas trop foulé qui est
comme kaka et que tu es très fort sur
internet apparemment on m'a dit qu'il
n'est point qu'il était en 3000 sur icc
etc bref et ils ont beaucoup de femmes
noires ou gary g royal a dit obama
beaucoup de 24 mai va être super fort
alors elway mêmes ont beaucoup de
joueurs tout court en être si besoin ou
qui vont être hyper x ou y à un certain
objectif de la saison quoi il doit
gagner moi car mon sens bien en fait
champion de france donc ils ont vraiment
être très favorable sur lancers les
seuls qui vont mettre une telle équipe à
l'oreille à villejuif qui est déjà
inscrit aussi je pense peut être assez
fort il y aura déjà un grand maître
jonathan duras où il doit avoir d'autres
joueurs titrés après je sais pas jusque
où derrière ils auront des formes noires
ou en tout cas un grosse équipe aussi il
ya deux équipes il ya un petit derby
entre guingamp et nantes
normalement on file aussi et qui
peut-être un peu mes enfants tout mais
bon c'est du jeu sur internet ils ont
des bons joueurs
tout est possible attention un patator
un y à patates en bas tu as tant qu'ils
sapent appliquer bêtement un peu le
joker donc annoncera sans club quoi et
ouais mais peut-être que c'est un inter
des types en train d'équiper son club du
coup sûr la fin
à la fin on pourra faire une petite
équipe lidstrom
on n'est pas très fort je te dire tu
joueras du coup non je pense pas ok je
laisserai les gens perdre ouais celle ci
si vous le maintien à la rescousse jeu
le titre les amis on va jouer contre ces
maïs humains les amis ici par avait déjà
approché slimane charge j'en ai marre
des déceptions nadal ouais c'est vrai
comme coach à ce titre c'était dur très
dur
c'est pierre pentus commandes que quand
tu joues en plus ait un puissant c'est
frustrant moi j'ai joreige le compte n'a
qu'à j'aurais été là quoi je l'aurais
perdu mais j'étais là quoi j'aurais su
j'aurais mis la pression
j'aurais perdu comme les autres quoi
mais en fait tu es moins puissant que
quand tu regardes tu sais quand tu
regardes tu es impuissant le gars va
perdre nakhal écrase et à un puits sans
compter dans tu dis bon bah je leur as
quoi tu y crois j'étais gay ou plusieurs
fois plus contre lui j'ai déjà battu
temps des arénas sur des parties serrées
non mais sur une partie tout est
possible de toute façon autant sur un
match on btu tea party maturation
fonction de perdre sur une ça peut être
la bonne foi c'est oui il ya un petit
peu négligents dans l'ouverture par
exemple tu joues bien me suis dit
comment ça à s'énerver façon je me dis
que le salut blitz de valley que j'ai
joué où j'avais vraiment beaucoup de
pression sur internet et je voulais
faire quelque chose c'était contre
mcgill douceur mais bon c'est pas perdu
donc pourquoi pas fêter le vandale était
là
ouais j'étais chaud mais bon je sortais
je sais pas si j'ai déjà raconté mais en
fait je sortais d'un tournoi ça c'était
la deuxième partie du tournoi qu'elle
est
j'avais perdu clairement contre un
tricheur à la 5ème d'ailleurs qui a été
gérée du site juste après mais c'était
sûr en fait donc voyage avaient fait
quatre sur quatre la partie si je gagne
5 sur 5 vous compte magnus et je perds
contre le gars qui gruge et après je
refais quatre sur quatre n ous été chaud
donc en fait non donc 3 6 3 sur 3
parcours pardon dont elle est à 7 sur 7
contre une moyenne à 25 56 3 26 c'était
trop chaude ouais j'avais mis dans les
gars connu que j'avais battu j'avais mis
20 coups à prague un mandat j'avais dû
mettre 20 coups à un ou deux autres
grands maîtres
donc tu vois j'étais quand même chaud en
fait quand manu c'est arrivé j'étais
très chaud et c'était en fait c'était la
chance que j'ai eue ça motive quand tu
voyais juste un but contre lui n'a
objectivement quand tu fais un tournoi
était à écouter à 7 sur 7 c'est le monde
mais c'est le meilleur moment pour jouer
les gars comme ça oui donc en vaches par
contre ça se passe très mal an pour saab
ouais il a chuté contre un joint un
petit côté daniel gallardo sur sa photo
là le joueur de plus car je trouve je
vais avoir une deuxième dame c'est pas
une très bonne nouvelle
il n'y a pas de perte est sûre dans une
protection aux vaches en double dames
pendant les français on est un peu en
hesse ouest où la de procme cyanogen but
en huit ans bouton qui est au rendez
vous et on est mais en fait on a on n'a
personne en fait devant wii ce qui se
passe sur lutteur faut qu'on se rassure
avec avec pipe ou bien 4 192 jours ouais
il faut qu'on se rassure et cookies
poupe
allez on se rassure l époux qui poupe
y a pas d'algues vertes cocktail soleil
sont quand même pas si loin que ça c'est
cornetto qui m'a appris à faire ça se
rassurer ses grâces accordées tôt que je
fais ça c'est en propre châssis qui m'a
appris à faire ça compte à tous les
échecs et qui perdit viens on va
regarder nouvelle on va se rassurer
donc là on peut voir petit couplet joue
contre achat ah bah voilà petit papou
net déçoit pas tardé en fait ouais c'est
cool c'est cool c'est cool c'est cool
alors on se rattrape avec milou et que
milou est allé 1000 ou encore contre
korolev c'est très bientôt de secours
bah c'est cool c'est cool c'est cool on
se rassure avant se rassure avec qui on
peut un bond cette baisse est toujours
leader mais ou pas parce qu'en dise
alors qu'elle moins de points maintenant
non non il n'a pas hélas plus le strict
et l'appui le strip
mais on a dit de 65 et cp 33 aussi qui
nous rassure tous plus fous les revenus
et comme dans la première moitié na waie
au prix là au prix d'un gros effort est
ce qu'il aura pas là mon prix le vent a
compris l a compris la stratégie du
sprint il fallait jouer très très de
temps d'arrêt ouais il m'a l'air d'avoir
bien compris le truc quoi il se met dans
les roues
il fait beau c'est les autres et il va
arrive à venir il va venir les radars et
d'enchaîner au sud
bon pourquoi de personnes jouent la
viennoise qui correspond à son style
offensif kevin avec des poubelles des
retours dame ne sait pas que vous
manquiez doit prendre ça un support les
poubelles c'est aussi d'avoir des
poubelles
ah oui je ne voulais pas la théorie donc
dû toujours des pressions merde quoi
c'est bon et la viennoise sais que je
peux jouer je prends parce que juste
j'ai une ligne forcé légalise facilement
léman ou pas de problème non complet je
crois donc à ton père de la route est
droite mais j'ai envie de dire qui tu as
joué la viennoise autant jouer le gambit
roi
d'accord avec toi autour d'un fou après
ouais les variantes est adhérente
potable pour le pin à tort ses passes
pas perdant pour les blancs du tout
alors bien sûr mais juste et noir
peuvent égaliser ne pas avoir de
problème tout très vite s'ils
connaissent bien mais c'est un peu comme
toutes les ouvertures moins joué ça
dépend toujours de les connaissances de
l'autre avec les noirci et qu'on a un
bon système de tubes combat va être déçu
sous lui poser de problème moi le truc
après c'est que j'aime bien les kwassa
ce vraiment mes bêtes écossaise
c'est un très riche comme aux versions
c'est vraiment dans mon style écossaise
c'est pas le gros des poubelles c'est
ouvert ça en fous partout mais le
problème c'est quand je suis vieux et
des beautés comme serré flatres et le
truc c'est que je calcule plus aussi
bien qu'avant mais quand j'étais gamin
ce calcul et bien c'était bien et je
joue comment les grossesses du coup
parce qu'il ya en fait je déjoue tout ça
qui est bien tu peux jouer fou et trois
sur fou c'est ça je suis calais b 3 ou 4
si je pouvais à quatre cavaliers je peux
prendre en ces sens je les joue tout mon
coeur s'est tari les plaisirs comme dans
tout il faut toujours varié les plaisirs
sinon après ça devient chiant c'est fait
hier mathieu j'ai mis un gros blanc
après une phrase de ce type la crème
bien sûr le balèze
ouais j'aime il balade hier mathieu
demande combien des lourds est mort fait
aujourd'hui moi je dirais 2723 alors est
ce que c'est un mort fille qui aurait le
droit d'apprendre la théorie et de
matches à risques ça n'a pas le droit
mort si la tension normale morphil
époque je pense qu'il dépasse pas 2002
ouai 2002 c'est dur de ce conte 2002
scan en longues peu quand même mais à
mai après un mort fille qui bossent
ouais il arrivé à mon avis très vite
très vite très très haut mais en fait ce
qui prend le mors fils à ses besoins
oui les jeunes a tellement évolué depuis
que effectivement vers une cause de
l'atome il serait loin mais après j'ai
écouté un truc génial je suis vraiment
d'accord de bên fine gueule
même si je suis pas souvent d'accord
avec bell est là pour la peine je trouve
que c'était très bien ce qu'ils disaient
parce qu'il ya plein de gens fin tu as
commis l'américain forcément on lui
parle plus de murphy cannes ou quoi
c'est à plein de gens dans les clubs
c'est qu'ils sont 2002 2003 2004 qu
israël morphine ninna nanna j'aurais été
plus fort que lui je l'aurais battu ai
dit ok c'est vrai probablement mais dit
je leur demande la chose suivante fait
qu'il suit and alive hug contre 15
personnes comme été capable de le faire
morphy si vous êtes vraiment plus fort
que lui évidemment ils ont déjà du mal à
faire contre une personne quoi donc
israël pour mettre en relation le talent
par rapport au fait que les partis sont
pas très propre mais parce que c'est une
autre époque quoi je suis un mais déjà
rien pouvoir faire ça sur des postes
complètement dingue
quinze partis à la veille que tout va
sans doute c'est juste hallucinant
pour moi ça ne pardonnera lucie assez
fou et ouais mais bon c'est pas le
morphing quoi est fait toi t'es nul moi
je m'appelle paul murphy
moi je fais pas la vague a été veuve à
la règle en fait j'en fais jamais ça me
saoule genre des fois dans la voiture
zéro match par équipe des gens comme en
asie ont fait une partie à la vague du
tout
nous c'est pas ça a joué moi je m'étais
entraîné pour progresser en calcul ouais
mais actuellement j'en serais pas
capable
une part ses pneus ça reste quand même
assez abordable combien on peut vous
faire justement bas monde de hockey
déjà au delà d'eux je pense que même
deux parties à 5 ça chauffe déjà vu dans
mes deux c'est très chaud mais au delà
c'est sûr que je commence à me tromper
et ya des coups illégaux et 1
j'avais fait une à deux avec flatter en
fait on a arrêté après 15-20 coup c'est
pas que j'avais pris position sèchement
à savoir la migraine
oui messieurs
julia vlad justement ça me saoule en
fait ou alors je propose ne diposant
toutes les parties là je peux gérer et
c'est encore plusieurs les parties elles
mêmes en fait si votre adversaire moi il
est fort plus c'est dur on a un sens de
souvenirs des jeux n'est pas parce que
du coup les positions sont très
inhabituelles pour nous donc ça nous
force à à réfléchir de manière très
différente du coup ça nous fait bugger
rien un truc à savoir par mon union
soviétique les simultanée à la boxe
était interdite
ah oui pourquoi c'est très mauvais pour
la santé auquel vous avez fait des
études ça défonce le cerveau en fait
grief fil à des stars aux trésors
enfouis en fait juste cool avec le
personnage disent que ça a créé des
troubles psychiques et que c'est pour ça
que c'était interdit et vlad qui en a
fait plusieurs malick il a suffi d'un
sport est totale
non mais il m'a dit qu'il m'a dit qu'il
sentait que c'était ce n'était pas
quelque chose de bien à faire en fait
corps numérique ça faisait tout avait
mal à la tête que tu faisais des
cauchemars après qu' il ya quelque chose
qui n'allait pas mais c'est un très très
gros efforts et surtout que ça sert pas
à grand chose finalement non bahia c'est
un côté un peu spectaculaire ça traîne
un peu aux calculs aussi mais le faire
de pleins de façon plus saine
oui non mais une partie à la vague c'est
différent c'est en fait c'est en la
stimulant là bas est une saveur mais
s'annonce tendu comment ça on sait que
plusieurs en même temps c'est dur mais
après c'est comme tout c'est comme les
variantes c'est comme tout c'est un jeu
auquel tu dois c'est un jeu juste
différent tu dois dire entraîné céline
prix est le spécialiste français sachent
ministration de citadel assez
impressionnant des djs mais si utah à la
boxe est vraiment impressionnant voilà
les gars qui font 8 10 12 15 parties
c'est ouf écart ayez foi qu'il en fait
35 45 en carrière
ça paraît
impossible en fait j'ai allaité score
tout à fait correct en plus bien sûr s'y
trompe pas quoi ça paraît juste fou en
fait c'est même pas que de la mémoire en
fait c'est non mais c'est le fait de
réussir a ordonné dans ton cerveau gère
des casses quoi ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça la difficulté c'est vraiment
que tout ce mélange déjà deux ou trois
tu galères 50 c et puis c'est long c'est
très long c'est d'épuisants d'un
raisonnement physiquement oui tout doit
redonner un truc dans ta tête pendant
trente-huit c'est peut-être une chose là
je dois leur donner pour que ça reste à
l'intérieur je suis beaucoup avec autant
de joueurs ça dure je sais pas le record
du monde combien d'heures il a pris
durant existe est énorme
ouais bon genre ça se compte en 21
vingtaine d'heures peut-être même plus
je sais plus si noir et blanc mais je
crois c'est un truc énorme je sais pas
exactement 20 heures nous dit olivier
alors est-ce que milou il va réussir a
toujours été paul a alors bilou et c'est
du chaos ne ressentent plus 0 jusqu'ici
pas écouté très vite dans sa ville
tombée dedans c'est bizarre quand il est
chaud il s'adapte pas du tout à la
cadence et milou nom fut là bas il n'est
certes pas oui bien sûr bill vol ah bah
va encore aller ce jeudi pour lui il va
en avoir marre des français il appelle à
zéro en outre une petit bout qui s'est
bien adapté 1 il a pris la tête
il a pris la tête et là il a compris
qu'il fallait toujours été un peu juste
ouais
une affaire h 4 h 5 n'a pas faire de
cheer up tu prends maintenant il s'est
adapté
moi je mise sur petit rocker le
responsable prend un deuil à avoir peur
ils pourraient mettre leur au centre
s'ils ont des deux ou à deux en d2 il
est pas des deux trains adam c'est un
joueur pleutre et dans l'esprit 4 à 5
après on enfile taf
oui alors là elle doit être
impérativement s'est ouvert le centre le
5 par exemple semble au vu de la
réaction très très nécessaire parce qu'à
attaquer on voyait alors tombé 3 on va
perdre un peu de temps après la d'amour
jeu bong ariel ses 48 parties on nous
dit olivier one c'est fou 48 parties et
c'est un personnel à gentiment vers y
est je passe tu connais un petit peu
bouger j'avais dans des tournois
explique marc muller très court et très
cool et même l'année oui je vais le
faire plaidé et agi c'était fantastique
joueur un tournoi l'an side event le
matin d'un tournoi en portant rapide
qu'avec des gros prix et il se retrouve
dans une partie 1 bat guesdon mort
subite
il avait les blancs du coup il a
réfléchi 40 secondes à son premier coup
joxe et du caoutchouc au temps et à la
fin il a perdu autant une finale de roi
où il y allait à dame
il savait pas qu'il avait pas d'un
crémant on sait que la donne un très bon
donc je laisse tomber complètement à
l'ouest un barème est ça qui fait la
beauté du personnage et ça fait son
charme
puis j'ai été content plus ouvrier bon
bah c'est pas grave j'ai perdu autant à
messac est cool c'est qu'on devrait tous
faire ça oui mais je prends pas au
sérieux
que les femmes extrêmement doux l epr ou
là des capacités assez impressionnante
mais là pour s'amuser
ouais sur quillan potentiel de faux un
pompier poupe la sacrifier la qualité
pour mater la dame en a deux au fait on
se rend compte que alors pas du tout
participé à la partie et commence en
train d'en parti pour les parfaire
aveugle en ses troupes
vous voyez pas de secret bouquet poupe
creuse à l'appui poupe il creuse l'écart
à mon avis il est bien parti et bien
parti mais un site peut finir le tournoi
je sais pas quel est son emploi du temps
passe mais ça m'a un entraîneur aussi
dans des cours
donc selon son agent d'un patient qui
puisse aller jusqu'au bout placerait la
très mauvaise nouvelle pour les français
et barbare contre crypte talent ouais
mais bon un petit peu s'entretuer du
coup il et il est fort avancé arena là
depuis quelques jours avec j'ai vu sont
donc plein de fois tu as attention adam
t4 des 4 est ce que c'est bien ici ou
pas arrivé de en fait tu grattes à 2 la
jouer en tout cas jurado yves lacam est
ok on a les deux tours sur la première
motion
il ya du constat je me suis un peu sur
le web c'est chaud comme party est un
avantage mental comme substantielle pour
les blancs il ya un gros avantage rethel
pour les plans b encore une fois ça
mobilise et les biens authentiques les
plombs si la joue très vite et c'est
vrai qu'il
ça se trouve les menaces de matha kalos
vous quand tout mettre sur la tâche
j'apprends tu vas faire tourner en
barrage 3 est donc presque pas
d'attaquants réalité dont on sait qu'ils
ont que la dame du potentiel ou le canal
et ça manque un peu de deux forces vives
alors elles se lavent de sa tour
peut-être 7,2 des idées avec des troupes
pro des trois ans moment donné a pas
pour l'instant
alors il sait très bien joué il veut
changer les dames et à près de 9,6 bas
c'est juste fini parce que le tueur à
200 bambins à tomber et il y aura un
réseau de bâton à chelles qui sera donc
organisons b ont dit qu'elles allaient
encore plus forts dont il n'a pas vu
mais si tu faisais tout reprend g6
quelques restons g8 mater mais bon ça
serait pas justifié moquer il sa force
la bombe
ça va peut être vous il a bien joué le
barbarian grosse partiel barbarians et
bananes vertes du coup c'est banal
barcelone et où joue entre walid al fath
0 alors du coup il a une grosse mission
ou à lille plus alpha 0 voir ce que ça
donne mais enfin attention et un jeu
eric duc tuân voilà qui est en train de
rattraper à je veux enchaîne contour
noir qui se chauffent philippins ces
philippins
ça ressemble un peu aux impôts la
dulwich et mellila ils ont le petit
soleil dans le pib mais je ne voyais pas
tout petit soleil une banane verte car
des bananes vertes en photo de profil
c'est joli avatar de bananes vertes
west couverture car lycées 6 ok ça tes
disciples balade verte ou à risque il a
commenté hier à un truc et qui parle
comme moi d'accord forcément une
personne de qualité tout à fait il est
forcément qualitatif
il ya un petit peu de
ban à sortir son foulard m mais n'a pas
assez j'ai l'impression ouais mais en
fait la rentrée si c'est fait exprès
québec connaissent pas quoi sur pareil
simek connaît à tes dents dures et
surtout après un quart et lieusaint que
la presse qu'on peut prendre des saints
où il ya jusqu'à sept
le problème c'est que rappaz découverte
etc notre cavalier de son tour gbit des
déçus on sait que ça s'est mal passé
mais c'est pas fait encore si par
bonheur surprend de g peut-être que
ouali doit être plus trop si c'est pas
vrai mais aucun état de se transformer
lui aussi fait curieux 5-6 sera obligé
de faire quoi là tu vois déjà il prend
la prison horrible non vous apprendrez
tu prends de g tu commences à attaquer
ça ça va bien se passer très vite en
fait ouais je sens que ça réussisse à
venir
il ouvre juste la tour elf ou des deux
pièces extrêmement passive d'edouard
qu'elle ait du mal à se développer mais
je t'avais dit qu'il allait faire
oui bah tout ça parce que j'ai un peu
oublié par sauver son pion de
saint-narcisse avec tempo surtout
cavaliers enfin c'est ouais j'ai du
couple alain dewerdt devrait pouvoir
retourner alors attend la faute y
réfléchisse parce que
elia système français mais c'est là
c'est triste
pendant assez longtemps
ouais je fasse aucune taxe est ce assez
longtemps ouais mais ça a l'air de
marcher n'ont pas eu envie de repartir
aussi sec
oui c'est sûr mais bon il de nouveau mal
du coup du coup il est de nouveau mal la
viande hachée l'éclatement à troyes aube
ou moment là très intuitif et pour des
raisons concrètes du coup ça ne marche
pas il a joué trop vite
ouais et walid a parfaitement exploité
après cinq ans loin d'être fini
mais on a un peu de mal maintenant à
organiser nos pièces fallait plus
calculée au moins deux fois et fils
d'ahmed france est très naturel ouah par
sa décision un peu douteuse
stratégiquement nous rejoint m6 il veut
laisser 5 du coup voilà dans tout le
monde deux presque
c'est un peu décevant on a vu pire
il ya le set sur à défendre pour 17 ou
juste le goff jean berrou yves un peu
perdre toute la boutique le tour 17
et la dame elle commence à être un petit
peu à l'étroit
ces 4 40 m pour voilà on va il est plein
de tempo sur des coûts qui vont nous
être utile avec les blancs et les noirs
ça fait très stérile puisque bouger
saddam pour bouger saddam où il a doublé
tour c'est vraiment la galère
ouais las
une désorganisation totale de l'espoir à
toute façon ces scandinaves n'est pas
terrible 3 oui y'a pas de maths
non le cavalier premier set et voilà
alors oui mais bon les pièges étaient
pas mal tenté la part des sept
il a cru que j'avais un match très
bizarre dont il a oublié qu'il y avait
le clouage parce que ça doit y aurait dû
tout de suite ou encore pour s'en sortir
ce n'est pas cela
mais là bas mais il a il a calculé cette
souffrance est il à dire d'un bref trois
fictions oui il a forcément vous l'ayez
courage vous plaît allez passer de façon
à la banane verte son sort
miraculeusement marée mais bon il joue
dans l'esprit quoi ouais c'est la
scandinave quoi ça s'est bien terminé
ça avait mal commencé mais il se bat
bien mais je pense qu'il est très très
déçu il a pas du tout rond et m'en fout
en fait il faut comme un lapin il a dû
donner sa dame mois un show oui je
regardais tous ses sens je te réponds
juste du calavon fait tahrir d'attaqué
menace rien d'anodin pour tous on
descend que c'est encore mieux tu t'es
cloud donc bien sûr c'est juste
incroyable
je ne mérite pas le bail signé comme ça
je vais faire une deuxième partie
et là on tombe en quoi une qualité de
moins des pièces vous revient plein ciel
ou la qualité va récupérer mais la
région gilles parent c'est juste une
finale car don't see a une bonne
technique des blu t'a dit ça me fait
marrer
il tente le beau jeu ouais mais ça
marche pas elle est perdue tout
tellement tentant de beau jeu mais la
clc le beau jeu kamikaze là mais c'est
dur de faire le beau jeu c'était dur des
fois dans les nouvelles tendances et
mariam aussi je veux à tout prix faire
marcher une variante carrément hyper
jolie et je force un peu moins il sait
comment ça marche pas d'un rien ouais
mais ça marche pas systématiquement fait
5e au site a craint shenzhen est
peut-être que même la ganière c'est
chaud après il ya plus que 40 secondes
cheveux blancs et du chaos mois chez moi
je pronostique la victoire de bananes
banane verte autant de connexions
je pense que les street parties mérite
de gagner autant résumera mobile n'a pas
progressé avec les belges ou des groupes
distincts des loyers secours induction
donc son que techniquement c'est un peu
un gâteau avec les blocs ouais ouais
mais c'est pas très juste à temps
selon qui il tombe alors roy 33 demain
ça va être une belle femme récupère le 4
il aura mis le temps mais il finit par
jouer 3 7 km ou deux et c'est dur parce
que le roi va goûter les vins des
réseaux de bateaux sont pas là si
l'autre commence à faire le bon plan est
quelque part en jouant bien il a forcé à
faire le bon truc
ouais là je pense vous qui court avec
son roi un verger pour pas se faire
mater d'ailleurs c'est juste de revenir
réussissent de colmater de rien faire et
de le laisser jouer quoi comment tu dois
laisser la tour en sept semaines parfois
en provoquant les coups tu prends avec
des bons coups quoi ouais bah là il est
encore pas été très précis avec les
blancs ça va se jouer autant bilan
l'anoci est pas d'accord on dirait que
janot crème okwari la lie quand plus
vague
bref il n'a pas le bon plan c'est vrai
c'est moche que van der sar hague
bon après ça c'est pas de sa faute il va
gagner
du coup ils interdiront tant elle est où
cette partie cannes bananes vertes et
attend et on se fait en tout cas pour le
moment il a du mal coopi poupe un peu
qu'on garde à ceux qui suivent aussi
hocus pocus
oui il est très chaude il a tout gagné
[Musique]
wei à l'art d'être chaud le joueur
anglais le demi a même dit que les seuls
à avoir un problème de son apparemment
oui
bon moi on dit ça me le fait des favoris
fret ouais ouais si cécile faurite
frêche c'est que
ces cas c'est que c'est vous qui avez le
problème à la main du court duel entre a
grommelé le craignent un ouais c'est
pour un peu voir ce qui se passe quoi
les poursuivants poursuivant il était le
leader ex-aequo hocus pocus il à 100%
ouais il est pas mauvais d'avoir à
partir de quel score pas si la traque il
est riche et je pense que c'est la
question qui va se faire huer alors est
ce qu'il va voir m6 des choses que ce
soit à sa portée du coup brest cammas
est facile oui voilà donc le plan de
renouveau du fou et très standard un
rappeur du spo tulle peut-être bon alors
du coup ce qu on basculerait pas sur une
autre partie soutient le traître oui
surtout oui mais bon we made you my band
bien son pseudo valeureusement veut pas
dire ça on dit que ça non mais là et
s'il a foutu et 13 secondes pour batista
va pas être un problème
il a raison mais il est cité n'a pas le
choix
du coup il faut que d'autres se font
cela serait l'élan way bayard et lycéens
du coup il ya barbarian le barbarian
yacco crooner qui est contraire à illich
du coup noailhac o'conner meco connard
c'est pas un connard ils abandonnent
souvent à partir quoi aviver ont du coup
nous a du coup non mais on aime bien
quand même avec son pseudo
c'est à dire que co connard porte bien
son nom non non au second degré oui
d'accord moi je pense que c'est un truc
à bien qu'on prenne à berne est sympa
ouais opératoire qui remonte en sixième
il est bien oui mais tu es que 1800
c'est bien mais lui sont las de ses
chances au final le futur 1050 chasse
comme c'est qu'on vient sur lynch est
froid qui a 300 points d'écart soit 13
cents sur les trois oui oui c'est vrai
que ça monte mots sur les choses
ouais ils sont plus généreux tant mieux
alors du court et leach peinture ou
quatre qui attaquaient a si bien même si
au fond domine plutôt le fouad versé un
poignard au décès donc visuellement il a
usé weiler mieux mais du fait que quatre
effet pas si facile en pratique alors
après il pourra manger des six est
peut-être à 6,4 pour moi mais il se
défend plutôt bien godard là non ouais
elle sonic son coquet alors du mal à
faire revivre son fou il ya deux clans
seraient tombés d'accord et des mois
bien même si ce pas wipro de la tour
paraissait très très longtemps et vous
qu'il arrivât jugé
j'essaie un jour mais bon pas mal de
problèmes comme ces cinq est faible f5
un petit peu et surtout ce visa du tour
down
c'est le piège rentrant des satires
entre partout ouais ouais si ce n'est
pas vraiment la cause des noirs au 17
décembre
tu vas rentrer qui écoute le stream qui
se dit bon quart dont il s'est moqué
barbarian du coup très patriote coco
qu'audard barbarian qu'il est noir et
qui est plutôt bien
maintenant qui vient de manger j'ai tran
la manger tous les pions ce tir ce qui
est très heureux du coup c'est bien plus
de points sur li chuck mais ils sont
plus généreux alors après des fois j'ai
même eu des élèves ou des gens qui
m'écrivent dur et je préfère jouer sur
les pièces que j'ai un plus gros
classement mais en fait je leur dis
souvent m et enfin si tu préfères tu
préfères le site ou quoi c'est une chose
mais ici c'est parce que tu sais juste
psychologique pour avoir plus de plus de
points c'est un peu dommage quoi ouais
alors vas manger tous les
non ça pose pas trop de problèmes
techniquement pour barbarian qui
donnerait un tout petit souci c'est le
fond qui vient en c4 et de pions mais
qui filent et quand même parce que tu as
du mal à s'est pas fait encore un geste
est des fois fond c'est quand même hyper
monsieur j'ai pas l'impression de faire
plus de choses ouais après il veut se
recyclant où j'ai deux du coup il a
réglé ses problèmes très facilement
ouais si alors et tarifs le pion ce
serait beau très beau que ça marche
s'il trouve que ça marche et je vois pas
arrêt des t-bonds c'est rigolo contrôler
toutes les cases de la tour a déjoué
après ça doit être humain je pense parce
que cette cinquième essai thomson
soixantaine forteresse moyenne les
pattes cas où tu perds mais les
sauvetages octobre c'est eric naulleau
dès lors comme l'est de la baie saleh
n'a vu que tu gagnes tu appartiens à la
fantasy à partir et c'est par ce que je
vois vite ce genre de truc alors
barbarian autres petits bobos blanc
parce que s'ouvraient non à ton avis
c'était maman gamblin c'est pour quand
bling et je sais pas on saura un jour si
le labo noir de l'abonnement de chasse
comme être vraiment à progresser mais
franchement il ya beaucoup de choses
site en dessous de 1800 je trouve qu'il
ya vraiment énormément de contenu après
au dessus il ya aussi du contenu mais je
dirais en dessous de 1800 c'est vraiment
un au brain quoi ouais t'as beaucoup
outil vraiment beaucoup de choses pour
progresser
après au dessus de 1800 1900 c'est bien
mais c'est vraiment à compléter avec
avec des livres avec un entraîneur avec
des cours collectifs avec l'analyse de
tes propres partis à fond enfin
mais jusqu'à le convoyeur jusqu'à 1000
7008 quand même tu as si tu fais ça et
les vidéos gratuites sur bitstream
je fais les deux largement assez de
progrès c'est vrai je te cache pas au
dessus de 2000 il va falloir faire plus
de taf jouer des joueurs ciblés
globalement ou par tous les outils et le
saut s'est pas forcément effectivement
plus de 2000 c'est plutôt dans la
fourchette que tu as cité de nom c'est
super important
après tu apparemment je sais que j'ai
pas mal de potes qui font des puzzles
rush avant l'heure pas leur parti avant
les tournois pour s'entraîner tout ça
donc d'apparaître outils qui peuvent
aussi aider mais c'est plus un
complément après oui mais c'est bien
pour se maintenir en forme tactiquement
s'échauffer fait chanter des choses
sympas et pas t'en fais pas trop de
personnel oui à ce pour le coup c'est
bien pour centrer d'un calcul aussi pour
tous les joueurs les problèmes tactiques
et les proches ou les joueurs qui ont
1200 en plus ce qui est bien c'est que
vous pouvez choisir le thème des grilles
sacrifice de qualité je sais par fila de
surcharge élimination du défenseur est
comme ça vous pouvez vraiment ciblées
oui ça d'un très bon nous tiens c'est un
excellent outil vraiment un
cette partie qu'est-ce que ça dans une
bataille anti contre le canadien contre
le fou dans cette finale une égalité
matérielle c'est chaud c'est assez chaud
j'avais une tendance déjà un préféré les
noirs il ya un petit peu en fait le
premier qui arrive à six drones en
arrive à peine à atteindre 500 suis un
chassé par être quatre ça va être
intéressant et les blancs le blâme les
droits en d4 et les blues sont un peu
plus rapides a priori donc c'est pas
grave soit moi juste réorienter notre
cavalier certainement via 17
c'est un peu triste oui ça que je suis
pas fan en fait double échange de trop
de noirs qui en décèdent va pas comment
les blancs perse en fait de l'autre côté
non non je pense que les noirs crayons
etc en pratique en plus la ville est un
montage de quatre des cinq essais de
faire entrer le fou mais bon ça doit
aller et du coup elle a rappelé aussi
que vous nous disiez dans le dans le
chat si vous préférez du coup faire
votre arena nous greffer sur une arène
chaise comme si vous que ce que vous
préférez en fait il faut situer une
arène qui correspondent à peu près obama
quant à elles doivent être les âges
israël doit parler tous les jours sur
les chameaux nadj de la 13h30 us
qu'après cinq des six bien attendez pas
dû goûter les fautes kisan ouais parce
que les blancs
cinq ici après sera bien sûr impossible
parce que l'on décide défendre cavaillon
c'est simple de 20 pouces et le roi
mais maintenant groupes des droits c'est
qu'on peut plus trouver le cavalier qui
défendons à 6 ans qu'on a essayé d'un
terrain troqué à six contrats sont donc
jouer cavalier bessette pour laisser les
plans mangel 6 nous manger à saintes
débarrasser notre faiblesse et jouer
juste sur les droits mais au pmc que
maintenant le site fera b4 et on voit
des cadres objectivement
plus on doit être doit être nul je
tirais n'inquiète pas de pincettes final
que très tendu j'ai l'impression d'un
petit lait noir quand même sont en train
de de prendre enfin les faire voir des
cartes
ouais je n'ai parlé au tout début la
finale cette lutte pour pour la case
centrale
le truc tellement dégueulasse mais ma
foi c'est de trouver contre 1 5 1 est
bon ça doit être nul cette finale le
jour sous le regard et ont foncé 4 à
tout prix vous assure qu airbus a340
avec 4 du beauf un après alors après n'y
a pas d'écart ouais non parce que j'ai
encore l'option enfin ça se calcule ce
genre de choses même si tu peux pas
aller chercher j'ai 2 contre l'ac que je
regardais mais juste dans le temps de
manger des 6 et le pion peu court plus
vite paraît en plus du coup et on en met
un peu plus tôt prendra pas fait soit la
même chose selon l'option ou unchained
ça serait sûrement bon pour les rasoirs
voir les captures g3 se calculerait oui
mais vous tarifs jamais vraiment que
j'ai trois des cinq à échanger des six
contre quatre et après la baignade gens
fous le fou bouche à un moment donné
mais après on se fait un peu oublier les
choix doit faire un nul sinon tu peux
perdre cavaliers à quatre hélices et
donc du coup
une bonne performance de petits boudins
blancs ouais du coup ça les barbarians
ouais mais relish risque est notre
leader quoi allécher qui prend la tête
alors et lille qui affronte gildas
jacques kamoni ce sont bien les tués à
gaza ces 1
c'est un espion de démente et quand il
viendra pour qu'en cas encore un veto
commentera way dans toutes les parties
qu'on regarde y'a souvent cette colonne
h ouverte pour le monde voilà il envoie
le bien attaquer sur la colonne est donc
alors du coup il ya un bel à mon poste
un peu simple pour le cavalier blanc
pour l'instant il défend le pion g5 où
il a préféré mettre la dame n'est pas le
problème c'était d'alger c'est un petit
peu n'a pas forcément changé les dames
on peut peut-être à l'eau h2o jouer la
finale et la finale est très bonne pour
les écraser
mais je dis aussi de gagner vite du cdh
à rennes précédents tels que en bateau
fini la partie mais c'est de toute façon
tu vois cet été vous incombe et la même
position par exemple avec un pion v6
pour les douars peuplé de la cet
du coup la tour dans la colonne a déjà
beaucoup moins claires et là y'a trop de
trop on voit que le foot cases blanches
des noirs est juste très passif lui
aussi
là c'est écrasant non mais on est quand
même pas mal hein dans ce tournoi ouais
pourrait aussi parfois même mangé le
cavalier elle sent qu'elle se retrouvait
avec le bon cavalier que le move est
faux mais je n'en fais pas une idée en
fait de prendre
pas grave on l'a c'est bien parce qu'il
peut pas faire faux moi j'aurais bien je
me paye puisque sinon stratégiquement b
si c'était sympa jambes et six coupes
roxane canadiens 5 et juste
les touffes compagnie j'aurais pris son
quart à l'histoire de m'en débarrasser
oui elle est chez les ch au
chassé-croisé entre relish et les pipes
ou pour signer la feuille unis du temps
mais la crise et 6 et carrière prend 1,7
qui doit signer la feuille aussi leur
destinée l'anglais je gagne et tout du
coup là il a payé une lanterne ou au
cours ou cus peau qu il continue à tout
gagner
il a dit sur 10 mais jouent moins deux
parties met plus de temps
ouais bah du championnat culture sur
thur qui est pas mal aussi un bien sûr
il faire un bon ton dans 2 sur 10 mais
je contre solti aysat il est dangereux
c'est un petit favorite sur le papier
dangereux pour tu retires 505 qui fait
un gros tournoi aussi non il est blond
abbas continue le rush et on parle pas
du puzzle c'était une blague ecoplus m
comment perdre 100 points lots distincts
tchèque fait une arrivée 3e
c'est ça les arénas sa toux mal se
passer les arènes pour le coup je monte
des jardins font beaucoup moins forte
que tu affrontes j'amène puisque je n'ai
juste pas dans cet acte
l'article sur les arénas qui commence
dimanche il est sorti ou pas sûr tu as
comme je profite ce jour une autre page
pour je n'en aie pas que je sache
parce que sorti ce matin mais ne
trouvait pas sorti cet article je sais
pas d'en apprendre mais je l'attends
juge jetant un oeil parce que ça
commence bien on est prêt c'est bien le
premier dimanche d'avril à france gall
et sur le sens que j'aurais bien aimé le
partager avec les gens paient déjà pour
leur façade on m'avait dit que c'était
officiel mais ouais ouais mais c'est sa
vision pas sortir ouais c'est ça en
avril tous les jours tous les dimanches
à 5h alors est-ce que ça a pu ne pas
plutôt à 18 heures d'ailleurs alex
puisqu'on est une changement d'heure ils
ont été présents dans les deux cas ça
nous change pas grand chose
non mais c'était juste pour un pour le
dire mais c'est censé commencer dimanche
pas donc je n'y ai pas l'article voilà
j'ai juste entendu parler aux films que
j'ai pas du tout les noms c'est pour ça
quand j'ai pensé tout d'un coup ouais
non moi j'avais puisque j'aurai besoin
de la ii où la france est c'était un peu
space space mountain luge fil et un fou
non il ya l'influencé cette influence
est arrivé en france et 7 ans
je comptais des pièces à nouvelle
rigueur tranche des cats avaient l'air
même temps mais certainement pas y avait
comme tout à six car il est ensuite j'ai
caste pas peut-être l'idée difficile
avec une culture n bien affaibli les
pratiques sont fous en bessin pas trop à
la défense du roi donc les cartes
blanches sont très faibles ou
certainement du cavalier 4 ya deux
points f3 c'était un petit puzzle rush
là il gagner la partie sur le champ et
jolie à celui-là ils ont souvent plus
dans l'est pour le coup donner un peu de
leur âge si les thématiques d'orage
salle ty raté une pièce comme ça en un
c'était joli comme un gars bien à tort
qu'ils jouent au cuss donc en fait je
veux qu'on aille le voir je propose
qu'on aille le tarn avec elle et c'est
une partie importante vous stoppez le
soldat rochus s'est qualifié le droit
bordel je dois mais j'ai le droit à
bordel alors tu connais la rave celle là
quand même
oui mais tu le droit tu n'as pas le
droit des gages et quels jeux vous droit
du coup tu connais bien des dangereux
bah il a le droit bordel et le droit
d'être dangereux de ce tome 2 de son
football à y occupe j'ai balancé cancun
dame drôle de voir le prend en tout cas
non je ne te respecte pa occupe toi dans
le château mais chez vous il écrit votre
tactique et a pris le cavalier mais ça
marche et ça marche est peut-être plus
après son 15e en battant que moi je crie
la donne de savage avait fait la fiesta
c'est super nes super déjà des grosses
conneries pour voir si les gens le fil
ou alors du coup quel est ce qu'il a le
droit bordel la droite se sert des
rockets mais c'est rien on sait de l'eau
n'est ce pas très grave
whittier ranger 4 est hélas non oui on
est pas mal on est pas mal en plus on
n'a plus petits bouts qui a 50 points
normalement affaires 1er 2e là quand
même
ok c'est encore mais la 50 minute mais
on commence à être pas mal en fait c'est
là où quasiment la dernière venue s
occupe enfin parce qu'après on à milou
et puis après y'a plus personne
patrice blouin sud l'archévêque aviez le
droit puis céline bancaire auquel j'ai
le droit ils m'ont choqué ou non mais il
est bien qu'il avait le droit
là il fait une très bonne ouverture il a
un avantage certain à mon avis à la
sélection et donc une plus et puis son
avantage cet aplec alger le droit du
coup la lancée en devenant l'ancien logo
hays est très heureux de choula et
william thies items un petit canon mais
ça va il a vu pire et où le roi balor b6
si besoin
roi des deux c'est encore un coup qui
nous permet de javel moindre soupçon
sion hocus pocus sont levés
ces envois des deux noms tu peux faire
grand chose qui évoque un soupçon de la
gueule des partis interdits car à part
le fait qu'il ya souvent des petites
complainte des rois te qui me dépassent
en fait maison et prendre c'est un col 6
oui oui mais moins tu vois je peux
comprendre une pièce empressé de les
chanter juste super ok les deux côtés
ben là parce tu fais de la mer touquet
3g dans une coque nous regardes tu vas
te prendre des chèques père tourne tempo
ça
c'est vrai que moi j'ai plus fous et de
jets gagnent sur la pierre d'un prochain
un petit peu plus agressive mais pape a
tort ouais bon mais c'est encore chaud
c'est pas si simple pour qu'elle joue
droit non pas ian white room plus
oui mais ça moi je sais qui c'est pas
atépa stable encore non après c'est le
cas d'ailleurs historique malgré tout il
craint pas grand chose dont il a le
temps je dois dû fouler cette tour des 8
kg 5
c'est vrai là où candidats avec les
banquiers weihan il va faire trois coups
pour ce grand cas lors qu'il devrait
toujours dans le coup le fameux roi de
tournai 1 mais sur un parti pour partie
iii pour essayer d'expliquer mon roi des
deux quoi oui à une pause justifié ouais
bah ils furent justifier ces couffins
géométrie surtout penser d'eux parce
qu'en plus je dois reprendre une mère
d'un jour ans le 4 way et l'ag de
derrière alors est-ce qu'on peut situer
où j'ai cinq ans mais les fuites à leurs
forces et sinon va perdre 2 le fourbe et
c'est sur une fourchette qui avait trop
haut trop balade avec son n'était pas
facile honnêtement a pu diriger dans
c'est vrai mais parfois en fait vous
cherche trop compliqué juste d'être
simple à mon avis ouais
du coup c'est a priori pas quel j'ai le
droit qui va stopper notre très mauvaise
classe et d'ennemi public numéro un
focus
voilà deux façons faut qu'il faut qu'ils
perdent autant tous les 15 qui vont
jusqu'au bout qu'ils attendent faut pas
la folle h le collectif ariane 5 a
annoncé 600 des quatre hommes qui la
joue plus longtemps possible bon mais
quand même ça surtout quand on a quand
même deux joueurs iront se rend compte
qu'en fait ils ont l'air de jeu beaucoup
plus ils ont compris la bonne tactique
en accueillant plus de pupi poupe
le truc c'est que du coup il jouera
jamais un joueur plus fort que lui je
connais son actif l'ex joueur portugais
qui a un petit baume le stream vient de
perdre ce foot c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle pour lui ouais époux au niveau
du cou qui va mettre le point ouais il à
reprendre la tête
ssl et avec l'ail et les champs ouais
ouais
dans les deux sens quand même gars
devant et de milou qui est quand même il
faut cependant sur 12 ha bah oui c'est
de faire mieux il ya beaucoup de joueurs
à 100%
après il ya 15 985 joueurs donc
forcément demain matin 8 tu pètes à
parier contre un peu importe ce qui est
un vrai jeu tu as peut-être pas
forcément un mec qui font rage quand
même fin oui tout à fait il ya tant de
joueurs que j'ai le droit il fait du ray
nice bat qui se procurent il a quand
même beaucoup de retard déjà
il joue pas assez vite en vrai il a 13
points de retard et a et u voit un petit
bout crée déjà reparti sur une game quoi
oui hélas car du temps bindels et j'ai
déjà une à une une écossaise jeu tout m
pour la wii je lui connais bien la
théorie aussi sur les côtes est du coup
on s'est raccrochée à une arena normal
aujourd'hui avait un bug est comme ça ça
ferait une belle arène avec plus de 1000
doigts oui voilà c'est sûr que ça monte
au-dessus de mes joueurs en face aux
cavaliers scène c'est beaucoup quatre
cavaliers 2,5 c'est une partie à hasnon
de kasparov donc les connaît il y en a
des tas mais je pense qu'en fait pipi
l'après moved à me2 oui je sais
certainement certaines qu'elles aient
des cinq sages ou air était moins bien
bon là il a déjà gagné oui donc tu vois
il enchaîne pop hip hop bas du cou à
celles qui jouent des joueurs pas assez
en dessous du vexin joueurs en plus très
rapide on peut marquer les points
la relish contre crystal harris en plus
facile gagnant qui n'inquiète pas
forcément attaquer dans le dur dans ce
tournoi une partie comme chaque cra mixé
avec h 4 mai kravitz les gagnants de
mémoire et comme chaque l'arnaqué alors
que la dame qui est taboue à chaque fois
à cause de mike ward position adam noir
et du coup il m en s'imposant en finale
il avait pas un choix peut-être ça c'est
dommage c'est le match que l'on rende
ward était très faible
donc gbagbo ça passe de certainement
gagnants a de bonnes chances de sauver
sa oui mais là je pense c'est du 50-50
pour gants blancs ou nuls à peu près
l'espèce que tu fais un expert de ces
dames impression mais le pion watch
toucouère assez vite je pense que là je
n'aime pas ce que vous soyez en
maintenant le jeu vraiment chaud à
rattraper
j'ai même pas sûr que tu manges et
détroit ce qui est ben decca juste 20 h
à 13 h et un cache cache je sais pas
bonjour moi j'essaie broncher la tour de
notre vie intérieure
après ça je pensais ok moi j'espère
enfin pression comme ça oui tu as raison
mais après je sais pas s'il y en a une
bonne gueule des cas ce que je propose
que le quoi autant de passes 4 à 3 le
servathon c'est nul mais non il a bien
joué c'est pas si facile
il a refusé la nulle cryptage du
couchage pas trop qu'est ce qu'il espère
il va faire un nul
et du coup ça va nous laisser ces
implants pip ou quoi ou puis poupe qui
peut sembler sais pas comment tu veux la
gagner avec rita mais même pas
ton jeu michael sirois b5 tomber vite
oui il ya toujours un monde dans lequel
ton adversaire
rip aussi où quelque chose
typiquement il pourrait sacrifier la
tour sur l'os permet les six ans darren
de jouer ça ouais mais je pense que pour
cent et l'eau s'en fout et je consens
selon lui c'est sûr non mais là tant il
y avait deux ou trois petits pièges pas
ouais dipj ajouté il publie donc encore
d une partie j'ai l'impression 62 et
ghazi race
du coup ces drapeaux mexicains ouais je
veux c'est l'art mexicain rêvons il est
français et je compte le gaffeur fou
alors c'est la petite main ministre il
alors est-ce que ça va compenser l'écart
et non non non ça compense mais la
foulée cinq ans même après gérard 100 kg
ici le point positif quand tu as
vraiment un trop gros écarts et l'autre
les gens commencent à me donner les
parties oui oui on peut décourager les
auquel jouent contre murray il doit
premier la fin et toi
du coup ils scorent tucson mm un peu
parce que là il va encore mettre quatre
points ouais c'est casse gagner pour
cook
c'est vrai et du coup ce qu'on gardait
pas une partie un peu plus bas au
classement se retrouvent un un habitué
de nos arènes classique alors mon gré
soleil
ouais bah tu attends je viens pin à tort
pinata les people by l'attaquent
oulala tronic latics or elle est un
rapport matériel particulier tour contre
3 pièces il ya des pions ouais la
tondeuse pions un trois-pièces dylan
attaque mais peut en gagner encore
ouais difficile à évaluer la fin de la
région du mali
[Musique]
je sais pas quelle couleur je prends une
cible encore les pièces le prince
laurent être offert une petite faim
défendu alain cavalier h2o contrôler un
cavalier autre étape c'est juste le
meilleur défenseur en fait vous avez
votre cavaliers coller à votre choix il
y aura jamais de perpète
s'il ya la dame celle qui essaient de la
race est de votre droit
c'est comme ça alors par exemple c'est
un fourrage de à la place ba c'est
beaucoup plus facile de donner des
déchets alors du coup c'est avec la
gamme de la zone bat et je pense qu'il
peut se passer encore des trucs pendant
une partie
il n'a pas perdu pour le plead à tort
donc pour qui c'est un film à thèse ou
2,4 ça ne trompe pas dans la mauvaise
direction non mais c'est quoi les
défauts des quatre manches et j'essaie
de voir mon nom mais dont vous aviez que
la tour tu fais avec les noirs lavette
la tour d2 moi je
c'est vrai qu'avec les cas restez
n'importe quoi c'est vrai si le
totalement foutu oui facile avoue aimer
son fond un sens avec ça avait l'air
attractif assez vite assez vite c'est
bizarre de balès cachet tranquillement à
8 dans le coin oui je pensais beaucoup
québec a triché puisque les trois
résultats sont possibles
donc ces huit foyers en difficulté
après faut qu'ils trouvent cavaliers le
cas cela plus qu'une minute gagnée par
des connexions aux performances de
pipeline à tort bien réussi à faire des
connectés sur l'adversaire donc qui tu
veux regarder j'ai vue en hongrie doit
passer j'aurais bien regardons grid mais
il était plus bas c'est dur de trouver
comme ça en fait tu allais sur le
mauvais et le mauvais il a été la plus
aux minces mais ça en fait le truc c'est
que ça sera pas facile c'est difficile
je la sais qui c'est vrai qu'ils ont
rien à voir en fait oui je viens de
faire un avis séparé d'un combien de
mecs qui ont rien à voir par rapport à
des mecs qui ont quelque chose à voir
en fait ils sont plus les léser les noms
française quand même beaucoup plus
nombreux que nous menons en réalité
mais attention sur le 1000 joueurs cette
personne les réunions du coup et il en a
perdu il a fait quoi
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas proches de
deux mille lots tout à l'heure
je regardais son profil par curiosité il
a finalement commencé lundi ne pas avoir
1900 alors si ça se passe plutôt bien il
allie la sacrifier si tu peux faire ça
lassé de non droit pour aller en d2 se
cacher après dame f2 est un peu des mots
mais bizarrement c'est le numéro de leur
dis quand même c'est par la paire fait
mais ici je pense qu'il veut jouer pour
le gard et que les noirs en fait on
mange pas le fou vous êtes se développer
a donné deux cavaliers cette fois par an
mais ici je préfère le noir on glisse
encore une fois les faiblesses
surclassement sont assez difficiles à
gérer
ok disent qu'il ya un problème
d'ailleurs sur les matches
donc y'a pas que nous et c'est seulement
résolu dessous trois heures auquel sont
optimistes
oui mais c'est juste pour sept ou huit
non je pense oui tu peux doubler tour
c'est le plan le plus évident c'est sûr
ouais le plus est d'anticiper un endroit
qu'elle du coup je vais du a6b 5-1
préparé par l'autre qui fasse on aura de
toute façon pas le choix faut à tout
prix qui sont sans l'aide de ses usages
immortel 8
je suis docteur qu'il ya personne dans
le chatt boya quelque peu quelques
personnes ouais mais surtout beaucoup de
gens qui jouent j'ai l'impression du
vert 1059 la pêche ou encore les jeux
sur ta main et pains chose un truc comme
ça tout 7,3 alors je crois d'aidé
probable arrivée à damas et trois à
damas trois rois des deux dames paix de
maths c'est joli c'est joli et il
appelle la famille et la stab ont donc
sur son jeu il y aurait pour ces trois
gravement à ce chômage et on voit du
coup à quel point dans les partis un peu
extraire des vraiment des puzzles rush
des problèmes ouais il était pas si dur
que ça que je les ai vus a battu la
direccte que dans des cases noires que
sur 15 ans avaient des problèmes depuis
le début mais gagner vraiment beaucoup
comme ça alors du coup mais du coup il
n'est pas bien finalement tu as perdu
une pièce le siècle vous mais juste
valeur une finale avec une tour contre
deux pièces d'art et en option on est
trois autres points des trois pistes à
gaillac pour le plan du fou je réponds
non enfin la faille calculé voilà je
sais doit on ce sont franck ça peut être
dangereux
je pense que de toute façon qu'ils
prennent de la tour du fou c'est très
bien
il a joué aux voix des deux alors les
deux c'est quoi le
plan c'est mal de perdre une pièce
perdue 3-2 c'était le meilleur moyen
reste encore avec arme sur le plus
endroit dominant et b sabella foot
français quand ils craquent complètement
à ces fous des six encore s'il veut
sauver les meubles
ouais mais sinon je pense qu'il va vite
être perdre
outre ces cinq peuvent être encore parce
que dans ces cinq tours il y aura les
mains du couloir mène cavaliers c7
mais mattel mat du pouvoir a raté le
match de trucs de caves byrrh et il y
aurait il à bien craqué dans le dos a
fait retour de fo prend bessac encore ce
qui couvrira oui du coup relish il a
peut-être échappé à la correctionnelle
n'a alors rien ne s'est vraiment pas du
tout dans l'esprit bah ouais mais il a
dû oublier que tour 6 4
on va la gagner et cadres va la gagner
avec 9
il a laissé passer trop cher et sans que
ça attendez quoi pour éviter les pions
passé lié et maman tourbe et 4,24 et le
curage qui file puis on viendra derrière
l'option a tranché le mot auquel années
plus tôt me latour la tour a dit henri
iv jeu l'accord avec toi que ok pour
amener le roi là je pense qu
objectivement seignol maintenant tombé
gâté beaucoup et naturel
4 mais c'est roger cinq ans mais du coup
tu crées 48 ans ont passé je pense que
oui c'est un suçon one 4k c'est bien
logique
ouais mais ça va encore créer des choses
quand même courir et g5 juste un échange
vous ramène le roi après il ya le
facteur temps encore une fois on a
combien donc les lots sur cet arrêt
navale plus fort et l'oas était pompier
poupe qui aimons lay lay line c'est plus
morizet l'eau en plus 1,2545 et je ne
sais pas combien à 27,28 mise en scène
peut-être par contre la place et que je
vais partir à 15h ça me va comme ça et
faire et ce souci pour aller au bout de
marc ela alors là du coup c'est parti on
la regardera jusqu'à la fin parce que du
coup ses nerfs et n'a vraiment plus
longue mais elle dure deux heures où
elle commençait plus la f2 du coup toute
façon la victoire de pompiers et
entériné les chiens y a personne qui
rate prendre c'est impossible
aucune plainte ce qui est toujours à
100% mais maison même si contrôle à 100%
qu'il en gagne encore 5 qui va faire 20
points ce qui serait déjà fantastique
parce que ces partis de cinq minutes et
il serait quand même derrière coopi
poupe
donc on te retrouvera seul demain ouais
ok du coup avec quelqu'un je sais pas
encore en fait on m'a pas dit en fait
personne ne s'est en fait non non non
non c'est pas ça
mais entre trouver un chemin du coup
pour l'aréna et bars bonne chance à tous
et moi ce soir je ferai le live à 20
heures pour les débutants du coup pour
changer un peu
qu'est ce qu'on a fait beaucoup de
choses dernièrement quand même pour les
joueurs d'un certain niveau entre les
candidats les machins et tout donc un
petit truc pour les débutants se fait
pas de mal merci à tous et à weight
merci et du coup à très bientôt à tous